en la noche de San Valentín de 2013
reviva steam murió a manos de su novio
han pasado 10 años desde que se conoció
el mediático caso en el que la estrella
del atletismo sudafricano asesinó en su
casa a la modelo abogada y activista
contra la violencia de género las
autoridades acusaron a Oscar pistorius
de asesinato premeditado luego de
encontrar el cuerpo de arriba con cuatro
heridas de bala pistorius en cambio
sostuvo que disparó luego de pensar que
los ruidos que venían del baño eran de
un supuesto ladrón Pero además del arma
de fuego la policía encontró en la
escena del crimen un bate de Cricket
ensangrentado con Rastros de piel de
arriba consistentes con dos golpes que
la modelo tenían la espalda el juicio
terminó con un veredicto que condenó al
atleta a seis años de prisión el acusado
pasó solo unos meses tras las rejas y
logró la libertad condicional para vivir
en la lujosa casa de su tío en pretoria
y llevar una vida prácticamente normal
en un país donde la violencia de género
se cobra una víctima cada 8 horas y
considerando el veredi increíblemente
leve la fiscalía apeló la condena y en
noviembre de 2017 la Corte Suprema de
apelaciones sudafricana Consideró que
habían suficientes argumentos
convincentes que no se habían tenido en
cuenta en los tribunales anteriores
escaló la pena y condenó a pistorius a
13 años y cinco meses de prisión
creemos que esta decisión de la Corte
Suprema ayudará a la familia a encontrar
el cierre Aunque sabemos que la
sentencia no traerá de vuelta a su hija
Pero sabemos que facilita las cosas al
saber que se han puesto una sentencia
adecuada
[Música]
Oscar pistorius ganó tres medallas de
oro en los juegos paralímpicos de 2008
en Beijing y más tarde se preparó para
competir a la altura de atletas sin
discapacidades en los Olímpicos de 2012
en Londres una competición que no le
dejó medallas pero en la que logró la
clasificación para las semifinales de
los 400 metros planos
10 años después de la Sangrienta noche
de San Valentín se cree que Oscar
pistorios podría acceder a la libertad
condicional de acuerdo con la legi
slación penal sudafricana que indica que
podría Acceder al beneficio tras haber
cumplido la mitad de la con